à peine élu joe biden doit déjà gérer
une crise migratoire historique son
arrivée au pouvoir a été perçue comme un
signe d'optimisme pour des milliers
d'habitants d'amérique centrale après
une mandature trump marquée par une
forte rigueur en matière d'immigration
beaucoup pensaient que l'administration
bailon marquerait une rupture s'était
d'ailleurs en filigrane ce qui
ressortait des annonces du candidat à
bayonne et d'aujourd'hui face à
l'augmentation considérable du nombre
d'arrivées le président démocrate semble
dépassée depuis janvier les etats unis
ont enregistré 30 % d'arrivée
supplémentaire de personnes originaires
d'amérique latine et centrale
rien que pour le mois de mars environ
168 milles personnes ont été prises en
charge par les agents de la patrouille
frontalière américaine à la frontière
entre les etats-unis et le mexique c'est
le chiffre mensuel le plus élevé depuis
2001 outre le signal envoyé par
l'élection de baden c'est aussi la crise
sanitaire qui explique en partie cet
afflux massif face aux images de
migrants arrivant à la frontière avec
notamment la dangereuse et parfois
tragique traversée du fleuve rio grande
et joe biden joue la carte de la fermeté
le mexique refuse de les reprendre
ils disent qu'ils ne les reprendrons pas
tout nous sommes en train de négocier
avec le président du mexique
je pense que nous allons assister à un
changement ils devraient tous être
rapatrié tous devraient rentrer les
seules personnes que nous ne laisserons
pas s'installer de l'autre côté du rio
grande
seule et sans aide sont les enfants un
discours qui tranche avec la posture
humaniste affichée par joe biden durant
sa course à la maison blanche
d'ailleurs des associations des deux
réfugiés ne l'ont pas oublié et rappelle
le président américain à ses engagements
en tant que candidat le président joe
biden avait promis d'accueillir 125
mille réfugiés durant sa première année
de mandat
mais au lieu de reconstruire
l'historique programme dit partisan
le nouveau président est en route pour
accueillir le plus faible nombre de
réfugiés depuis la création du programme
contemporain de réinstallation en 1980
pour tenter de répondre à la crise
l'administration américaine envisage une
autre solution verser de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent aux pays d'amérique
centrale pour que
gouvernance 10 va d'une partie de la
population de choisir l'exode une
méthode critiqué alors que des milliers
d'américains sont également dans des
situations précaires côté républicain on
s'engouffre dans cette première brèche
du mandat byden des sénateurs se sont
rendus sur place
long de la frontière profitant de
l'occasion qui leur est offerte d'ouvrir
les hostilités contre le camp démocrate
nous avons également vu un groupe
d'enfants qui venait d'être testé
positif aux copies 19
le centre de donna à lui seul rapporte
qu environ 10 % des individus qui sont
détenus sont testés positifs au kovy 19
ces taux sont nettement plus élevés que
ceux de la population américaine et
l'administration byden prend des
personnes qui ont été testés positifs et
les enferme dans des caches côte à côte
c'est inhumain c'est mal la crise
migratoire et plus particulièrement le
sort des mineurs isolés et le premier
véritable test pour joe biden des médias
américains rapportent que le sujet est
source de tension dans le camp démocrate
et preuve que la situation est
inconfortable les journalistes sont
tenus à l'écart priés de ne pas se
rendre sur place les médias doivent se
contenter d'imagés officielles ce qui
fait dire un photographe de presse
dans une tribune qu'abidal mène une
politique d'accès 0 à la frontière le
sujet cristallise les critiques de
toutes parts et les sondages montrent
une grande méfiance des américains
envers la politique migratoire de joe
biden probablement gêné aux entournures
locataire de la maison-blanche évite
soigneusement le sujet sur les réseaux
sociaux
ces publications se concentrant très
largement sur le contrôle des armes à
feu et la vaccination